started so
let me introduce to you our second
keynote speaker i'm very happy
to have meredith kunst here who is going
to talk about a quick start guide to
stoic parenting a very important topic
not only for parents
but also for everybody else who doesn't
have kids but has you know
there's kids running all over the place
in the world so it might be nice if we
had more stoic
parents so let me introduce meredith she
is
a writer living in northern california
author of the stoic mom blog she's a
mother of two daughters
and when she's not hanging out with her
family or blogging she works full time
in the field of science and technology
communications
you can find her blog at the
stoicmom.com
you can also follow her on twitter as
the stoic woman
and she has a stoic parents facebook
group which is
you have to request to join um that
is is uh quite a nice and helpful group
i think for anybody who
is struggling with um you know
the various vicissitudes of of parenting
which i think any of us who have kids
know quite well so that said i'm going
to turn it over
to meredith and thank you greg
thank you so much to greg and the
organizers of this event
for including me in this great lineup
today just wanted to say i
am also a midwesterner at heart um
i grew up in the chicago area i did all
my schooling there through high school i
have lots of friends and family there
and right now they're all telling me the
same thing
winter is coming so i wish you much
fortitude
in the days to come um and today i'd
like to talk to you about how we can
apply
stoic ideas to being a parent uh
first why do we need to well i think we
need
parenting help and support right now
more than ever
and as greg made the point maybe not
just for parents but for everyone
in our communities because we're living
through a pandemic
and being a mom and dad has become an
enormous
challenge right now um as well as the
challenges facing
everyone who's involved with children
today including teachers child care
workers
social workers etc this is beyond
anything that we have experienced
in our lifetimes before when it comes to
taking care of our children
and we're all doing more child care at
home and it's funny it's whether the
kids are infants
toddlers you know school age teenagers
or even adult kids are coming home to
live with their parents so there's
there's a lot
happening for people who are who are
dealing with children or even
young adults around 40 percent of child
care providers have
shut down according to the wall street
journal perhaps
permanently right now during the
pandemic kids are home all day with
their parents
schools in many cases are virtual
teaching is uneven
kids need help throughout the day they
don't have sports they don't have
aftercare in many cases
and the parents also are under a lot of
stress they're working remotely
or they may have had to cut back on work
or even
you know take a leave of absence or quit
because they have to take care of kids
so it's it's both are hard working
with kids at home is challenging but
also you know not being able to work is
a difficult thing so um the fact is i
think kids right now need a huge amount
of attention
and support but also their parents and
frankly everyone else but i'm
specifically addressing parents
and how we work with our kids we need to
do our best to
keep calm and carry on while we're in
this very difficult time
um with child care homeschooling work
dealing with a pandemic none of this is
easy so
fortunately we have we have stoicism and
i think
modern stoicism has a huge amount to
offer for parents and i'll explore a
little bit about why
in my first section as i talked to you
about how i discovered stoicism and how
it helped me
um when i first became a mother i felt
very overwhelmed
i was overcome by this desire to really
be a perfect mom
and to get everything right i i was
concerned about
mistakes i could make and this this is
from the very start
in today's world to frame it a different
way one of the defining
experiences of parenting is a loss of
control
uh this will kind of ring bells for you
in terms of stoicism
loss of control because even when i
first became pregnant i realized that
you know my body was doing all these
things i had zero power over
and i just had to go with it and then
when my first daughter was born and then
my second daughter two years after that
i quickly realized that my children were
unique human beings
many of whose personality traits and
behaviors seemed
inborn it wasn't something that i was
uh creating necessarily in in their
lives but that there's a lot of things
that they
they just were born with in terms of how
they behave and how they think
i it's uh you know if you've had infants
in your home
you know you it's very hard to organize
them to keep to a proper
quote-unquote proper schedule or all the
advice that you get as a parent about
how to manage things and when i tried
harder to manage them
their resistance got worse and the
anxiety increased for me and for my
husband
and it was really hard then to make the
decisions when i became
irritable so trying to find the the way
to be the best possible mother
have have best experience with my family
and also
have a life of the mind and a fulfilling
career not easy
challenges there were a lot of questions
um because my husband and i were
committed to raising our kids as
independent adults but
it's hard when you feel as if a lot of
things are
outside of your control and there's this
fear of making mistakes
mistakes that could traumatize your kids
or help prevent them
from developing a good character or
having a positive future
the stakes are definitely high um also
there's an issue of judgment around
parenting and how other people judge
your parenting and how the world will
judge your kids
ultimately so i looked for answers i
explored a lot of life philosophies
ranging from ancient greeks
to the american transcendentalists i am
definitely a fan of
thoreau emerson to the modern
existentialists
i was always interested in these these
uh thinkers
but then about five years ago i
discovered the modern stoic movement
and i really felt that it was a good fit
for the kinds of
of things i was hoping to grow i was
something growing courage
and to let go of things that were
outside of my control that caused me
guilt and stress
but to be able to uh uh cope with those
things
in in a more healthy way uh not focusing
on what had
little value but instead on you know
moral and ethical development
character finding the virtues i focus on
developing
my faculty of choice with wisdom justice
courage moderation the stoic virtues and
and working with my kids on those things
too
so um in 2016 i launched my blog the
stoic mom
and i really want to focus on applied
modern stoic life philosophy how how can
it help me
think about my challenges how can it
help with my family and how can i help
other people who may be in similar
situations to live in a way that's more
wise
brave and free and so
now with the pandemic we really do need
this much much more than ever
and with the way the parenting
expectations have changed in recent
years
there's a large amount of pressure on
people because we're in a very
competitive world
and a global economy and the pressures
to work with
and for our children to help them
succeed
are super strong um from my experience
in a really culturally diverse
city in california parents of all
socioeconomic backgrounds and income
levels
are striving to help their kids do well
and to somehow succeed in our world in
the best way that
that they can and as our kids get older
we know you know colleges only have so
many slots and so many scholarships and
we know our kids are competing with
others
in our state our country and even across
the globe so
we've seen people really in the service
of what's best for our children
go to great lengths parents for example
who were involved in the recent college
admissions
scandal uh so there you see just an
example of where
well-heeled parents were willing to do
anything to get their kids into a
certain school and you know i admit that
as a mom
i've felt the desire to control my kids
lives and to even pave the way for them
to succeed sometimes
though never using a legal means
thankfully at least not yet so
um i've realized though it's really an
impossible task and it's it's actually
misguided
it's not healthy for me or for my
children
to have that point of view that you have
to control their lives and you have to
pave the way for them constantly and
ultimately i work to handle all these
concerns
without falling into the trap of doing
those things being really controlling
becoming really frustrated and anxious
all the time that i couldn't
and for me that way is stoicism and so
that's why i've been working for past
several years to apply
modern stoic ideas to my life as a
parent
i'll just say a few things that it helps
with it's liberating
from the pressure and guilt and
frustration about
not being able to perfectly shape my
children not knowing always
the best way to help or guide them or
what that even means making mistakes
being imperfect
myself around my children uh worrying
about how they'll ultimately be as
adults
um so so you know it's not about
giving up responsibility for our
children of course not we have a duty to
be there for our children
and we're connected with them not just
common humanity but those circles of
concern
it's it's obviously i'm very committed
to that but the point is to becoming
more to become more rational and less
anxious
as parents more rational and less
anxious
and to give up some control
to our children especially as they get
older i know if you have an infant
that's not going to happen but
i will discuss a little bit more about
the ages of kids and how this can work
in a moment
um one second
in a practical sense um here's some ways
that
we can approach it so first with stoic
philosophy other people's opinions just
aren't that important
what's important is living by our ideals
and striving for the virtues
finding that moral core and having those
guideposts
as long as we're working to develop our
moral sense
our faculty of choice and drawing on the
virtues then we are good
we are good people and who are good role
models for our kids we need to
constantly remind ourselves of that
because of all the messages we're
hearing to the contrary
um do we really care about what other
families post
on social media about their vacations
their birthdays
their fancy material possessions and
their achievements with their children
um should that influence how we spend
our time
and our energy you know i just posed
that question i'm sure as stoics we all
know the answer
we should not care um and second we have
to realize that so many things
are outside our control and we're
frankly just all doing the best that we
can
and remind ourselves i'm doing the best
i can when things get hard because
things will
will definitely be hard uh when you're
working with kids
and uh we have to kind of accept that as
well and not just say this shouldn't be
hard but it
is hard um because a lot of things are
outside our power and for example some
of those things
as a parent uh are your child's
individual personality
abilities or interests how your child
gets along with other kids
the competition with other people like
it or not some people will try to impose
that on you even if you don't wish to
participate structural issues
inequities in incomes schools and school
districts
opportunities that are difficult to
surmount
and those things are are very
challenging
so when we think about how we deal with
some of the things that are outside our
control
i think the first line of defense is uh
to try to start saying no to the
thoughts that pop up about comparison of
our kids and our situation with other
peoples
uh we we need to work on not giving
ascent to those impressions
those just reinforce these social
pressures that have been building in our
society and that
are really counterproductive to actually
having a good experience
i think for you for you and your kids
and i'll get to more about that in a
moment about
the kids themselves and their their kind
of needs
and there's also something else within
our power it's the ability to say
no to more activities and to more
demands on our time as a mom and dad
that just create busyness we can
remember what marcus aurelius wrote he
said
most of what we say and do is not
essential if you can eliminate it
you'll have more time and more
tranquility
ask yourself at every moment is this
necessary
i apply that quite ruthlessly to
some of my my parenting uh requests
and even demands that i get uh in in
around the community and even for my
family but for example
uh as a parent for me in this category
are things like bake sales nothing
against people who love to bake
i am not a baker but you know that's
something where the parents are
often being asked to do things like that
not just
bake sales but other kinds of things you
could participate in
where there's a lot of busy work
personally i can say no to those and
just maybe make a small donation instead
um or organizing very elaborate parties
certainly i've been to some where you
wouldn't believe what's going on
um and it's it's a lot of fun but i
prefer to keep things simple um you know
my kids aren't
have been in sports pre-pandemic you
know attending all the practices or all
the games
i can't be there for some of the games i
work full-time and i have to kind of say
well that's something i've
decided i can't be there at 3 30 for
this game
uh driving them to extracurriculars that
are three towns away
on a daily basis which i know some
people choose to do and want to do and
sure i'm sure it's helpful on some level
but you know it's something
that i can say well i'm really not able
to do that or even things like cleaning
up
after them cleaning their bedrooms for
them now my kids are a
preteen and a team they're older but you
can start teaching these things
to younger kids too uh about kind of
where that boundary is
and this does not make me a terrible
mother um
at first saying no was very hard but
i kind of feel it maybe we do the
positive side too try to identify
the kinds of things that actually are
supportive of our children but you also
enjoy
or that you find bring you closer to
your kids and show them your
your values and uh what you think has
meaning about it maybe even something
fun like my husband had the chance to be
a dj at my daughter's school walkathon
fundraiser a couple times and
he's still known as dj bob to her
friends he connected with the kids
kids and the cause and i've been a girl
scout leader for over five years
i find it provides kind of real
character building
for the kids and for me through social
service and outdoor challenges
um but you know also i'm always there
for homework help and discussions about
friends and debates about ideas
but you know i simply know that i cannot
do everything
so saying no to the small extra things
and especially the things that are
really
calculated to just look pretty on social
media is really strongly supported by
stoic ideas
um as seneca said as he wrote nothing is
ours
except time we were entrusted by nature
with the ownership of this single thing
so fleeting and slippery that anyone who
will
can oust us from possession um so we
need to use our spark of reason as
stoics to figure
out of the things that are in our power
what's reasonable to do
as parents and what's not reasonable to
do as parents to support our kids
so we have to get honest about that
otherwise we risk a lot of burnout
or losing our temper or signing on for
more things and we can deliver getting a
reputation being flaky
with our kids with our community um and
we can do this with compassion by really
being honest with everyone in our family
about this and people may complain
they may be angry with you at first if
you say no especially even your children
mom why won't you pack me lunches for
school anymore um i've heard that but
you know you can bear in forebear and i
think it actually strengthens everybody
in that relationship also we have to
accept that our children are not under
our direct control this is critical
um there's sort of a myth in our society
oh why can't you know she control that
kid
he's having a tantrum on the playground
uh we we as
who our parents know this is extremely
difficult to do because
if we can't uh you know manipulate our
children in that way
we can just work with them and it's the
same with students if you're a teacher
so even socrates said that he had bad
students
students whose behavior was terrible and
who went off the rails and
his response was i don't control their
minds and all i can do is be a role
model
so sometimes it's kind of in the hands
of fate
of course we you know we need to keep
working with our children we feel duty
we feel responsibility absolutely
but we have to accept some of these
limits and try to get less frustrated
with them
um and so to sum up how stoicism has
helped me as a parent for
for this section of this talk i think i
would say it really enables me to
deal with the pressures the parents face
today in in
fairly healthy ways and i think that all
parents could benefit from a dose of
stoic philosophy i also think it's
helped
set my kids on a path of well-reasoned
choices
that i hope will serve them long into
the future so i just want to address
that
for a few minutes in this talk our
children
i've learned a few things about kids
that have helped me in this journey
uh one thing that i think is important
is that
um you know stoic ideals can help kids
develop
their own character and uh first a few
general thoughts and then a few
practical ideas
uh first a lot of parents today in our
society expressed love through
consumerism or entertainment for their
children
and uh i think stoics in the ancient
times were a lot tougher on kids they
really believed that characters
instilled through
things like exercise and sports and hard
work
and i do still think that we develop
virtue through work
it's it's it can't just be aspirational
exclusively we have to actually uh give
our children things to do
uh and that's more important than
possessions
obviously that this is to inspire kids
to have
uh kind of a stoic uh infused life and
uh
in doing that we also show them what we
care about when we ask them to do
something or we do something with them
through our actions and we teach them as
role models
uh i i think we they have to be things
that the kids do that require
effort on their part that are
challenging for example this could be
physical challenges
in my family when our kids express
interest in doing something
brave physically we encourage them to
try it
traditionally a lot of times that
wouldn't have been uh
done for girls you know in generations
past but
uh we we really encourage them for
example to try out for new team sports
that they
just have an interest in it takes a lot
of courage to work through the fear of
not knowing how to do it not being that
good at it at first and
um they didn't really have the knowledge
of the rules and
you know everything else about it but
they they persevered and they were able
to do much more i think than they
thought they could and
as a girl scouts also my daughters have
gone on really tough
camping trips and and overnight camps
where they've learned to do things that
i never would have done
at that age um like backpacking high
ropes
rock climbing sleeping out under the
stars for a whole week
and my one daughter wanted to do a camp
called gilligan's island
through girl scouts literally she came
back after having rolled around in the
mud
and all those i don't know five days or
six days she had they had made a bed out
of tree branches and that's where she
slept
it and she loved it she absolutely loved
it so i think it was um
a way to really try something that was
really different and
outside her comfortable bed and i think
that that
is very helpful sometimes um and in
family outings too you know we hiked
through a river together and we did
canyoneering
just opportunities we could take uh to
challenge ourselves
intellectually challenge ourselves i am
known for dragging my daughters through
countless museums and historical sites
to
expose them to culture and art and
history and science
that they might not have learned
otherwise
also work on challenges in the community
and in our world by volunteering
we've done service projects on
pedestrian safety mental health
feeding families of the hospitalized and
helping the homeless
um even simply asking directions at one
point
when we had the chance to visit japan
for a few days
i taught my daughters to ask where is
the bathroom in japanese and i sent them
off to talk to some some strangers just
to try to find out where the bathroom
was and
according to my 12 year old daughter
yesterday that wasn't that hard
so i thought that was kind of
interesting um in lockdown
in the pandemic with tons of new
challenges things that are tough for
parents and kids in a not very positive
way there's
isolation at home there's the need for
constant supervision for young kids
there's
doing school online which is not
inspiring
uh the boredom of staring at the screen
or you know the temptations of screens
for
fun activities like video games or
entertainment that could just
you know or youtube that could go on for
hours and hours and hours
missing their friends and for some
people dealing with with illness and
financial problems
so it's very hard for us as parents
um to face these things and to watch our
kids confront difficult things
but it really it turns out that this is
actually beneficial
recent studies have shown that facing
challenges or even
feeling uncomfortable can actually be a
good thing for kids
so the psychology research showed that
you know by keeping kids perfectly
protected from any adversity or
challenge
it can actually be harmful to them and
in the long term it can
potentially create anxiety or depression
there was a very
interesting article in the atlantic that
summed up some of this
research back in in may i think it was
childhood in an anxious age
and the author said that kids today are
perhaps more overprotected
more leery of adulthood more in need of
therapy
and many blame helicopter parenting
despite more than a decade's evidence
that helicopter parenting is
counterproductive
so i don't believe in helicopter
parenting or what some people call
bulldozer parenting too where you're
you know shaving down all the obstacles
for the kids
um and today my parenting is really
focused on autonomy
raising independent adults uh that was
intuitive
to me from from stoicism the strongest
predictor for motivation
in kids and teens is a sense of control
over their own choices so choices that
they can control things that can be in
their control
we need to let them choose those things
there's an excellent book called the
self-driven child
by william stixred and ned johnson
and they argue that a lot of times
parents are depriving children of
meaningful control over their lives and
putting them at heightened risks of
anxiety and they devote a whole chapter
to how parents mental health
can harm that of their children they
make a good point that moms and dads can
have a
non-anxious presence for their kids
and stop micromanaging everything from
homework to their friendships
i think stoic philosophy can really
inspire us to be less anxious
and more present for our kids and
really it's about focusing attention on
what matters that personal connection to
our children
support for their moral
or character development and that's
right in the stoic wheelhouse
uh so it's kind of thinking about
letting go of ceaselessly multitasking
uh and over committing instead how can
we be listening
how can we be responding to what's
around us and to our children
i like this quote from marcus aurelius
i've paraphrased a little bit
uh concentrate every minute on doing
what's
in front of you with precise and genuine
seriousness
tenderly willingly with justice and
unfreeing yourself
from other distractions all other
distractions
uh my kids call me or my husband out
when we're distracted while we talk for
example if we're looking at our phones
and
i give them a lot of credit for that uh
we try to do the same with our children
you know
when we're having conversation we need
to be looking at one another and
actually connecting and we can have
family times of day
at dinner for example or a family down
time where you're actually interacting
like a regular game night
and again this is for slightly older
kids but in a moment i'll mention some
things for younger kids
let's think about our children's agency
i've heard it said that stoicism is a
way of maximizing agency
remember the kids aren't performing
monkeys they aren't the puppets of their
parents who are orchestrating every move
they're people and when they're old
enough they need to
learn to make good choices and
commitments and figure out what
motivates them and
how to spend their own time it's not
easy with younger kids it may seem
impossible but we can there are ways we
can start pretty young
which i'll address in a moment we can be
good role models
in a sense showing the decisions we make
and how we choose to live our lives and
we need to devote
time to actually explaining that to our
children
like explaining okay you know for
example i got a mail-in ballot
explaining here's what the ballot is
here's how i'm making some of these
decisions here's what i think is a good
idea
here's what i think is not and how we
arrive at those decisions
and that's that's just one very recent
example but any kind of decisions you
make
that are major you can explain your
thought process to children how you
used your spark of reason to make that
decision and use the
the guideposts of of the stoic virtues
so um my husband i hope that we're not
forcing our kids to do things and saying
do this because i said so and
that therefore they'll be able to become
more full people and make
commitments of their own choosing of
course we hope that they'll commit to
doing
lots of loads of laundry and dishes
around the house but that's another
topic
um and my last segment i'd like to speak
about is
how do you present stoic ideas to
children and how do you work with them
to try to live in this way so when kids
are very young
it's hard to express life philosophy to
them you know their priorities are
different their own immediate
needs and wants are what they think
about they're driven by hunger by
fatigue
play competition with other kids and so
on and they haven't learned to use their
sense of reason or understand cause and
effect
or even really know that much about
other people's needs
or wishes they're very young
but the studies in neuroscience show
that kids from seven to nine
are laying down the structure for
reasoning in their brains
and that that that those areas grow a
lot around the ages of 12 to 13.
so i think that somewhere in there uh
maybe age nine or ten it can be a good
idea to introduce
some stoic or philosophical ideas a
little bit more formally with a few
high-level concepts about the dichotomy
of control
you know phrasing it in different terms
of course that kids can understand but
start to explain it
and the virtues and questioning our
impressions is a big one
even we can begin a little bit with
toddlers
at a young age we can talk to our kids
about
what what is in and out of our control
what are the consequences of our choices
how to question our impressions what you
know knee-jerk reactions to things
we have and why they might not really be
helping us or other people
i i kind of like to say in my blog i've
said stop drop and question your
impressions
um and my kids know what that means even
though it's a little bit more of a joke
but
like for example uh when my one of my
daughters was a toddler around age two
or three
she would get very upset about leaving
her friend's house when play time was
over and she just would refuse to do it
um so i started to try to work with her
more instead of this tantrum happening i
would try to explain to her
about other people's uh you know
perspectives
and consequences so the host family has
their own
schedule and that's not that's not our
choice but
they really they've decided that they
have to start cooking dinner now
um how you respond to that is in your
control you can change how you react and
behave
and think about this way remember you
you won't get invited again
if you don't leave when you're asked to
go um also what if this were your house
and you needed to make dinner because
you were hungry what's in your power to
influence
your next potential invitation and to
understand what's like to
be someone else um so kind of giving
kids a sense for how they could respond
why they should think this way that
bigger picture
weaving in little aspects of the virtues
about fairness
about self-control without naming them
as those
but just kind of really direct practical
uh questions questioning i like this uh
kind of coaching with the questions um
and explaining how making a good choice
will actually give them more options and
more freedom in the future to do things
that they enjoy
uh and another element of this
is so that's more about teaching kids
things that are in their control of how
they react but another thing is their
choice their faculty of choice
we can help them develop it early on but
we have to really
be careful about that i think limiting
it to two or three options at first is
best
like do you want to eat pears or apples
or peas or sweet potatoes or plan the
slide or monkey bars
because kids sometimes have difficulty
with a wide wide range of choices
uh but i think just a couple choices two
three choices that can actually help
them because it's very motivating
to kids to have choice and they need to
cultivate this faculty
and figure out what they you know like
to do and what motivates them
um and allow them to see natural
consequences
so they can gain some wisdom from that
too for example
your child refuses to wear a jacket
going outside and it's 30 degrees
and if she gets cold enough maybe she'll
remember to wear her jacket next time
you know you don't you don't force her
to wear the jacket maybe she'll remember
it next time
or you can before she leaves the house
you can say well if you don't wear this
jacket i think you'll be shivering
you'll get very cold you might even get
sick catch up catch a cold and get sick
and then you might have to stay in bed
all day
by yourself instead of doing something
fun this weekend
so you know i think it takes a lot of
time and repetition but
that can that can have an impact um and
kids having that experience where they
face the consequences themselves
that eventually uh teaches them
something um
so uh i think kids proto
passions what the ancients call these
involuntary emotional responses
are are super strong um and they can't
really control those initially you know
that
the emotions turn into bad passions very
quickly and much more readily than in
most adults they haven't developed their
faculty of choice and of reason and we
used to call this the red zone
when the kids would have a tantrum when
they were smaller
um and seneca said anger was a temporary
madness
um so i think that there are good stoic
solutions for that too to help
younger kids even you know the very
simple things that stos recommended that
we can also use today
that are also good for adults and we all
have that angry kid inside us too
sometimes
um counting to 10 or more counting to 20
taking deep breaths
distancing yourself from a situation
giving yourself
time learning to kind of
ignore other people if they're rude or
insulting or something like that
um and and uh this other little theme
i'll just
address very briefly is that uh stoicism
is great for
helping us not to take things so
personally this is hard for me too
but um like kids it's very difficult as
they're playing a board game
you know this your child's not winning
and then the kid gets super frustrated
and says
people are playing unfairly you know
this is not fair
but a lot of times it's not unfair it's
just you had bad luck and that's how the
world works it's not personal sometimes
i mean there are situations that are
truly biased and that's bad and we need
to call that out but
if it's really just something you know
this is you had bad luck
the kids eventually have to to learn
that and try to explain it but i know it
takes
takes a lot of time for kids to
understand that
then to kind of be able to float above
it and see it's not directed against
them which is
a good stoic concept this perspective
taking
i think helps kids and teens see the
bigger picture as as they get older
when you're young you think of all these
issues and problems just
are all the most important thing in the
world and anything that affects you is
just
this big problem this big issue uh but
you're kind of reminding these
principles
um with our kids is is really helpful uh
just briefly i want to say something
that greg said the beginning stoicism is
not about suppressing emotions so in
teaching these principles i'm not trying
to tell my kids don't have emotions you
shouldn't feel that way you should have
a stiff upper lip
it's really this cultivation of positive
character and a virtues and ability to
find
wisdom and joy through making good
choices and devoting time to the right
things
um not pushing down all the things that
bother us i would never tell a kid oh
you need to
you know be more stoic by not responding
in any way
um like if you saw the lego movie you
might remember the character unikitty
uh she's really funny she's like a cat
and a unicorn
and she suppresses negative emotions to
say super positive and bubbly
until she realizes at one point she
cracks she can't do it anymore and then
she turns red and explodes with all this
violent rage and
you know destruction so that you know
maybe a way to show your kids
um we don't we don't want to do that uh
we want to cope
well with our emotions we want to learn
how to deal with them and when and we
have what the stoics
call bad passions they pop up and uh
you know kids who aren't mature yet we
can still try to use
stoic inspired uh cognitive behavioral
therapy style
questioning of their misguided beliefs
or trying to get to the root of
why they're angry or sad and find what
the inner conflict is
and see if there's some way to to
resolve it or to let it go
and focus more on something more
positive
realizing that other people's opinions
aren't that important and do not
give us our worth as people that's
critical to both parents and kids kids
who are worried about the judgment of
others online
there's a lot of online judgment as they
get a little bit older
and in person at any age
so we kind of keep reminding ourselves
of this basic thing
i kind of like the quote epictetus said
i laugh at those who think they can
damage me they do not know who i
am they do not know what i think they
cannot even touch the things
which are really mine and with which i
live so
just to end this i'll just close on a
positive note i
i love the concept of stoic joy and just
joy in general
uh which a lot of times we're lacking in
our current society
um ancient stoics were not joyless
and modern strokes are certainly not i
think there's kind of a stoic
mindfulness we can cultivate to live in
the present enjoy
spending time with our children when
they are young or
or when they're older anytime and
sampling the banquet of life as it comes
to us
that is what this is all about it's
super important not to let our anxieties
or stresses obscure the joys of having
children in our lives
and um that's what i'd like to say so
thank you so much for listening my my
blog
is thestoicmom.com you can follow me on
twitter at the stoic woman and
check out the stoic parents facebook
group thank you so much
all right so i think we will go a little
bit over time in this session so we can
get a lot of good q a
in but we'll still have a slight
five-minute break before the panel
so we've already got some questions uh
coming up this is from ragavir
are there any books or videos that
introduce stoic concepts to teenage kids
without sounding complex yet
able to convey central ideas that's a
great question
that is a great question and um there's
the
the stoic handbook by
massimo pilici and greg lopez
i believe it's called the stoic handbook
um i have it here somewhere it's
that it's i think it's a good book it
kind of gives you day by day
uh things you can think about and do and
really
introduces it in terms of everyday life
but other than that there really isn't
one that's more directed towards
teens older kids or young adults it's
something i'm really
interested in myself and a lot of times
when i talk with my kids i think wow you
know i'd like to
i'd like to create a resource like that
someday um
but i think there's also a lot of good
videos out there that talk about
stoicism
and um they're you know
kind of even greg your introduction this
morning i thought was a really good
intro but
i think uh we probably need more
resources along those lines in the
future
i was actually going to ask a question
as well going back to something you said
really early on in the talk that i think
is
is very important which is um
not expecting yourself to be we could
say not expecting yourself to be the
sage right the perfect stoic
yes so how do you balance
i think a lot of people's worries as
well if i'm not like constantly pushing
myself
then i'm gonna start backsliding or i'm
going to
take it too easy on myself do you have
any guidelines
for you know not just parenting but
it could be anything in general for like
how to tell almost like
are you being stoic enough in the
situation or are you being too easy on
yourself or you're being too hard on
yourself
well i believe in what i'd like to call
compassionate stoicism i've also studied
compassion cultivation training which is
a method that's derived in part from
buddhism
and i try to weave that into my my
stoicism
uh because one of the things i've found
is that
many people especially moms really lack
self-compassion
when it comes to actually how they talk
to themselves and how they think about
themselves they're very very hard on
themselves
uh we we are i am i know i am very very
tough on myself so for me it's kind of
that
that sense of of loosening up a little
bit or
or less pressure and anxiety about
having to be perfect all the time i
think there's also a lot of cultural
pressures
on girls in our society to to be what we
think of as perfect
so this is a for me about realigning uh
what i think of as where my value lies
it's really
in having good moral intentions aiming
for the virtues in my choices
um those those guideposts are like the
baseline
and then it it's all this other stuff
that society is putting on us that makes
us think oh my god i
i can't cope or i'm a terrible mother or
something like that
um in terms of that balance i'm sure
it's a very personal question
you know if you're starting from a
baseline like like me of being
self-critical
i think you have to maybe get to that
balancing point of
i'm self-critical but i'm not perfect
i'm definitely not the stoic sage
and in fact there is no such thing as
the stoic stage on this earth right now
uh that we know of
uh nobody is really able to
really perfectly embody all the virtues
and all the practices so we're just
doing the best we can that was kind of
another line i like i'm doing the best i
can
um and i'm i'm doing doing what what
makes sense to me in this situation to
apply
my values and my principles
i think that fits in very well too with
as you were talking about the dichotomy
of control so here's here's a question
from doug
that could be like an entire book um
what are some examples of bad parenting
not just a general perspective but from
a stoic perspective maybe
i think the focus on shame is really
pretty bad in parenting uh that's one
thing
um like oh you didn't do this for me
my child you know didn't whatever it is
oh you know
you didn't do the dishes like i asked
you're a bad person
somehow conveying to your child that you
think that they have no worth as a
person because you
they didn't do something you asked or
you know
required of them that you know you
didn't get a goal in this game
wow you're a horrible player i mean i've
seen i've seen parents like
in sports say nasty things to their
children i think it's very bad parenting
um that's one side another side is you
know parenting that's conditional
essentially implying you know i won't
love you if you don't behave a certain
way
that's just you know i if you don't do
that then
i don't care about you anymore or you're
not you're no child of mine
uh there's also this idea of the
transactional parent you know
you do something for me i do something
for you um
and then there there's the expecting our
kids to be copies of ourselves
this is really dangerous i think a very
uh common pitfall is well you know
i did well in math so therefore
my daughter should do well in math
actually my daughters are both better at
math than i am but
just as an example you know there's sort
of this concept that
why shouldn't our children be perfect
copies of us
or or maybe something like i wanted this
in my life i wanted to do well at this
and i didn't and that's even more then
you put a lot of pressure on the kid you
know i wanted to
become a nurse but i my parents couldn't
afford to send me to college
you're doing this you know you're
becoming a nurse or a doctor or
something like that
so those are a few examples i would name
i actually have quite a few students in
some of the places where i teach who
who are pursuing career paths exactly
along those lines and then they confide
in me
here's a here's a question from dan how
do you tell a friend that is a parent
that they may be stressing too much over
being the perfect parent
without it backfiring um
yeah it's really that's a really really
good question um because it's
really difficult to talk to other
parents about their parenting or even
any of their behavior if they're not
open to it
so maybe uh somehow
role modeling how you behave um
might be good talking through some of
the choices that you make now i guess if
you're not a parent and the other person
is a parent
um yeah they may not take it well if you
try to give them specific advice
but maybe it's talking to them about a
couple of these principles just
in the abstract like oh have you ever
heard of this idea that
you know really we should just focus on
things that are in our control
or i mean i think i think that's a
really tough question i'd love to hear
other people's answers to that sometimes
so here's two things one from gerald and
one from aubry
providing some interesting suggestions
donald robertson is working on graphic
novel uh gerald says
that format may be appealing to
teenagers and then aubry says i read the
meditations to my six and three-year-old
at night
mostly to bore them to sleep but you'd
be surprised at how many great questions
my six-year-old
has about things she hears especially
over and over i just want the
three-year-old to go to bed i also read
uh sam turret's version and sort of
paraphrase
even that for them so so what do you
think about these
reading to kids and then graphic novels
yeah i think it's a great idea
i think reading to kids and the
meditations is a lot of it's really
poetry
and it's beautiful language some of it's
a little
harsh maybe for kids i might skip a few
things younger kids who are six or three
but
but i think it's really a good thing for
them to start
hearing from you also they know now that
you care about it when you read it to
them
and that has huge value uh
they'll remember that later on um that
you cared about it
um also sharon labelle's version of the
art of living it's an epictetus mod for
modern readers
this is a very good book i think i would
recommend that for teens too
um i'd like my daughters to read that
version it's it
brings it into modern language and helps
us to really understand
how this could be relevant today
so those are some excellent suggestions
any other questions from the
audience for meredith before we
oh uh piotr says as a father
three-year-old thanks on touching on on
the topic
yeah uh i remember when peoter had his
his wife had their kid and all the
announcements and
stuff like that that was a couple
stoichons back
you know it strikes me that one of the
the key terms that
epictetus uses in greek is philosophy
and we translate it as like familial
affection
um and in other ways so you can
translate it as love
and you were talking about stoic joy i
think
what you were saying is completely you
know completely right about that that we
need to have
joy within our life and maybe um you
know this is something that
hasn't been drawn out all that well in
the stoic theory of the emotions
maybe living out what epictetus was
calling this familial affection
may maybe a key component to that is joy
in each other's company and
in sharing activities and all of those
sorts of
uh things that's a great point
yeah i agree with i wholeheartedly
support that and i think
all these anxieties and stresses and
pressures that that we feel
both from society and from just the
experience of raising our children get
in the way of that sometimes where we
we don't see it but there's really so
much joy
from kids of all ages if we can kind of
cut through some of the noise of that
and have these
very present moments and that's harder
today with all our technology and with
the fact that all of us are online all
the time
you know in the pandemic but i think
trying to create those moments and those
experiences
is really critical and also those are
things that your kids will remember when
they get older
and that they'll tell stories about to
other people
all right well let me uh thank meredith
for a really
thought-provoking presentation
you